pues yo creo que la credibilidad ya se
venía desde el principio de la cumbre ya
lo vimos en las calles desde el
principio de la cumbre y la gente que
está afuera dice bueno prometieron
ustedes cumplir con el acuerdo de parís
prometieron ustedes llegar al comienzo
de la implementación del acuerdo de
parís con los planes alineados al 1.5 en
lo cual no ha sucedido con el
financiamiento a los 100 millones lo
cual no ha sucedido entonces ciertamente
pues ahí afuera dicen les creemos no les
creemos lo que acuerdan acá lo cumplirán
y la única manera de romper con esa con
esa falta de credibilidad es es dar
acciones concretas es hacer nuestros
planes de mitigación al cambio climático
alineados a los objetivos de parís
alineados pero alineados a lo que ya
está aquí se reconoce como el 1.5 grados
entonces necesitan los países
alinear esos planes pero ya dar
resultados en la implementación eso es
lo único que va a poder saldar digamos
esa brecha de credibilidad que ahora que
ahora existe yo creo que los ciudadanos
ya le han dado el espacio a los
gobiernos para hacerlo lo que
necesitamos es que los gobiernos actúen
el liderazgo político